you know in spare time when he's not the
director he actually thinks quite deeply
about deeper leak and has some of the
foundational results in this and
actually now will tell us an even more
fun stuff so yeah just on on this theme
of what are the what are the exciting
questions particularly in generalization
you know the topic of my talk today is
really about what I think is one of the
most interesting generalization issues
that's that's really been brought up by
this phenomenon of deep learning and new
there but not you know we don't have
results for for deep learning we have
results for linear this is joint work
with Phil long at Google gabbled ago
sheer Pompeu Fabra University and and
Alex Ziggler who's a PhD student here in
statistics at Berkeley so the phenomenon
that we're interested in is really
motivated by these sorts of observations
of strange behavior of deep neural
networks it's been observed that deep
networks can be trained to get zero
training error even for a regression
loss and still have pretty good
predictive accuracy
I say near state-of-the-art performance
you know you can you can improve on on
the performance you get when you train a
a deep network to zero
regression loss on the training data but
the striking thing is that that that act
that performance is actually pretty it's
pretty good so here's one example that's
from this you know wildly popular paper
that all these folks for at Google at
the time did on looking at fitting
fitting
Sipho 10 data set with its actual labels
and with noisy labels and fitting it
exactly so on the x axis of these graphs
is the proportion of flipped labels so
you know the left-hand side corresponds
to the actual size by 10 data set and
then as they progressive
we mess with those labels you know all
the way from the left to the right where
100% of the of the training data has a
random label assigned to it you know
they observe that actually you could
this is written this time to overfit
right time to fit the data perfectly
even with complete completely randomly
chosen labels you can after some some
period of time you can fit these various
various networks to get any data exactly
right
and yet on test performance you're
getting this this rather nice
this is predictive accuracy or not and
and so you know this is this is really
quite striking so I mean of course every
every data set has noise every every
real real problem has has a noise in it
but even even with test accuracy but I
guess it's a mislabeled
that's not my mislabeling I'm sorry
you're right I'm sorry I'm sorry it's
test era you're right so down here it's
performing well it performs worse as the
noise level they've all goes up you know
I had these back yeah you're right that
was not my correct labeling okay so the
striking thing is you know as you're you
guaranteed that there's there's noise in
this in this training set already but
but you know increasing the noise we
don't get we don't get bad performance
for for a predictor and prediction rule
that is perfectly fit to the training
data and actually perfectly fit in terms
of the the regression loss not just the
classification loss which is what's
Australian so this has been investigated
also by a bunch of folks including
Fisher and Daniel I think a year of this
this other work so you know there are
many more examples looking at this sort
of phenomenon where men much more
experimental we're looking at this whole
phenomenon where
you know actually you can you can see
that even a perfect fit too noisy
training data getting zero regression
loss which is a striking thing right so
there's there's none none of this
classical trade-off between the fit to
the training data and the complexity of
a rule or at least it's not at all not
at all obvious that there's any sort of
trade-off of that sort when you have no
room to improve the fit of the training
data so you know there's it's certainly
overfitting there's no possible better
fitting but without the usual okay so
think about you know this is this is a
10 class classification problem and
you're and you're getting 90% of these
things correct and and you're adding in
you know let's say 10% of the of the
training data has nonsense in its labels
and you're getting you know whatever
that is 20 25 percent correct when when
you know the baseline is 90 percent
error that's really striking you've got
you've got a very noisy data set you're
fitting it perfectly and pretty good
accuracy is
pretty good all right so so you know
what isn't isn't interesting about this
what what isn't isn't striking you know
and I'm gonna have a little bit of a
rant here so for long it's the top half
of the slide so first of all you know
having the number of parameters bigger
than the sample size there's nothing
very mysterious about that this is just
what we do in in nonparametric methods
there's nothing striking about that what
is striking is is you know not doing
anything to control complexity when
you're when you're working with but not
doing anything explicit to control
complexity so having more parameters
than sample size not at all mysterious
there's nothing new about seeing good
prediction when you've got zero training
error for a classification loss all
right because there is the possibility
that actually if you're working with a
regression loss with a method like
neural nets or ensemble methods or and
many other kinds of things then then
actually there might be some kind of
trade-off between the performance in
terms of regression loss on the training
data and that's it so you know I guess
the point I'm making there is this is
something that's been observed for
decades and this point you know is sort
of obvious it's strange to have to say
it but data is noisy you know we've
known that if you want to make
predictions from observations you have
to take account of the fact that those
observations are noisy we've known this
since the 1700s you know like 1820 or
something
Gauss published is his work on this gas
and Legendre and the plus and all these
people so you know it's not a it's not a
new thing if you're working with if
you're talking about generalization and
trying to argue that Y I equals f of X I
is the assumption you want to make you
know maybe that's going to give you a
step along the way to proving something
interesting but it's very far from
number two all I'm saying is there's
nothing new observations notice we're
all on the point I'm making there is not
about the analysis it's about the
observation so there's nothing new I'm
sorry if he can scale with within you
usually do some smoothing that's exactly
right I guess I'm saying that this this
having P bigger than n isn't a striking
thing you know P greater than or equal
to win so you know this is this is this
is really the world of nonparametric
you have to smoke that's right that's
right yeah
what I'm saying is you know it's it's
not a brave new world to have P bigger
than it really what is striking so okay
so in in the red I think what really is
striking here is we're getting good
predictive accuracy
you know presumably not optimal but good
predictive accuracy with zero regression
loss on noisy training data okay
and of course statistical wisdom says
you know we shouldn't fit the data too
well we should have some sort of
trade-off between the fit to the data
and the complexity of the prediction
rule all right whether that means
smoothing in the nonparametric setting
whether it means keeping careful control
of the number of parameters as the
sample size grows and so on you know so
somehow we should be doing a good job at
that trade-off of fitting the data well
and Lake City but but you know fitting
the data perfectly seems to be a
different regime so I think you know
that really is a striking and a really
fascinating phenomenon and certainly if
we want to understand generalization in
deep networks I think this is a really
central issue okay so there's been a
bunch of work on on this sort of
question using using different kinds of
meth investigating different kinds of
methods so work on on things related to
nearest neighbor rules so so simplicity
all sort of interpolation nearest
neighbor methods with appropriate
weightings of the the nearest neighbors
that that actually interpolate
results about about their performance
the results about general regression for
particular kinds of curls so nonlinear
functions of polynomials all for the
Euclidean inner product random matrix
analysis of these kinds of work on on
smoothing methods so kernel smoothing
with with singular kernels and you know
I guess this is the the exact an example
that actually dates back quite a bit
longer than you know the last there's
this recent work looking at again
applying around a matrix theory but the
case where the sample size and the
number of parameters are growing growing
together and approaching some constant
value and understanding how things
behave asymptotically in in a linear
regression setting so this is the
asymptotics that they compute a closely
related sort of things we look at and in
this very recent work that looks at
linear regression with with random
features random Fourier features in
particular so it's considering a linear
regression problem where you're you're
doing this this sort of interpolation
and understanding those specific cases
understanding the performance of those
interpolating Leah British
okay so it's quite a bit of working in
this little area that's popped up in the
last what we want to focus on and I
guess a few of those papers have focused
on is visit this setting of this
question of the performance of an
interpolating prediction rule in the
perhaps simplest possible setting where
where you and that is a linear
regression very classical setting so let
me introduce some notation that we can
be specific about about the result so
we've got covariant vector X and I've
written it as lying in at Hilbert space
you know you can think of it as just
some Euclidean space finite dimensional
but very very high dimensional and real
valued response variable Y for this talk
I'm just going to describe things as XY
are jointly Gaussian and an named zero
but you can extend it to the South
Gaussian case so XY a sub Gaussian and
the conditional expectation of Y given X
is linear in X right so well specified
which you know in the gaussian case
it'd make things makes things much more
convenient to stay in the gaussian case
yes but it's but it's this is not a
sexual
okay so the notation that we that we're
going to use to specify a linear
regression problem there are three
things we need the one that's most
important is the covariance of the X
Factor's right and their mean 0 so we
could just write them as this outer
product and and do a spectral
decomposition and the eigenvalues of
that that covariance matrix are the
critical thing right so we'll write them
as this sequence of decreasing eigen
values and since we have a complete
complete symmetry you know there's
nothing special about any particular
direction when we're doing linear
regression you know it's really only the
eigenvalues that are going to be
important so that's one ingredient
another ingredient is the least squares
parameter vector theta that minimizes
the expected squared error call that
theta star and then the the prediction
error the expected squared error of that
least squares okay so these are the
these are the three things that specify
a linear regression problem and the
particular kind of estimator which two
is the minimum of norm estimator so so
okay so we're interpolating we're in a
big-enough dimensional space that we can
interpolate we can get zero squared
error so so get every single y:i exactly
correct well so which of those
interpolating solutions are we
interested in we're actually the one
that has the minimum norm if you're
doing the solving the normal equations
you could think of it as taking x
transpose x pseudo inverse x transpose y
so our data right so just to be a little
precise about that we think about
capital X as a matrix with n rows and
and these rows might be infinite and and
why is our response vector so this is
our training data we want to interpolate
the training data so satisfy this
constraint that x times theta equals y
at every point but you know as long as
we're in higher dimension X theta minus
y norm squared is minimized and subject
to that constraint we want to consider
them
gnorm it's a minimum talk norm parameter
and that of course corresponds to taking
a pseudo-inverse up here alright so and
criterion of interest is the access
prediction error so we write it as R of
theta hat if theta hat is the solution
to this minimum norm squared parameter
vector then we're interested in its
expected prediction error versus the
expected prediction error of the optimal
minimize the expected squared error of
that prediction and you know things
nicely close and we get that this is
just equivalent through this covariance
matrix to the error in our in our
estimate theta hat is as an estimate of
theta star as weighted by the by the
Sigma and of course this is where these
lambda rise matter right this undereyes
determine the importance of different
parameter directions right if we make an
error in a direction where lambda is
large that's very bad for prediction
error if we make an error in the
direction we land R is small it's not
such a big deal this is one of the one
of the ways that the lander eyes are
really important here and of course
we're interested in this overfitting
regime where we can actually interpolate
the training data we want the x times
our theta to be equal to y at every
point and so the question we're asking
is you know when can all of the label
noise that's in these Y eyes be injected
into the theta hat in the sense that
we're trying to satisfy all of these
constraints right we're taking all of
that noise and and it's certainly
playing an important role in setting
theta hat and we want that to not hurt
predictive accuracy so that's at a high
level the question that we're asking
here ok so so here's the result you know
up to constants we get a
characterization of the impact of that
of that label noise on predictive
accuracy so for any linear regression
problem and remember it's specified by
the co-vary
matrix the prediction error of the best
linear prediction rule and the parameter
vector for the best linear prediction
rule if we're in a regime where we can
interpolate right so so we can have a
sort of in in n degrees of freedom then
okay so we define K star as sort of a
dimension of a certain subspace and I'll
say what this means in a moment it's
just some condition that defines K star
with with high probability the excess
risk so how much worse we are then the
best linear prediction in terms of
expected squared squared error is
bounded by so there's a term here that
depends on the scale of the of the best
linear prediction rule and and you know
various are the properties that we
expect to go to 0 as n gets large right
and and then there's the second term
that's more interesting this one is you
can attribute in some sense to the label
noise and we'll say a little more about
this later but this is the interesting
term it grows with the level of noise it
depends on this K star over N so K star
better be small compared to n and it
depends on n divided by some other
notion of a certain kind of effective
rank of this covariance matrix so I'll
say what these things mean in a moment
but you know turns out the second term
also appears in a lower bound right so
up to constants you know this is really
the right quantity it's telling us what
the excess risk looks like alright so
what is this little RK in capital RK
they're effective ranks so we've got our
our eigen values of this covariance
matrix remember they're ordered lambda1
lambda2 they're the big directions the
one that ones that matter a lot we
better get our estimates right in those
directions and as we move on down we're
getting smaller and smaller eigen values
so this little RK is an effective rank
when we ignore the first K dimensional
subspace the biggest K dimensional
subspace right so ignore lambda 1 up to
lambda K and whatever whatever is going
on in those highest energy directions
look in the remaining subspace and look
at the total energy in the remaining
subspace divided by the biggest
eigenvalue in that subspace right so
this is sort of a notion of effective
rank of within that subspace effective
rank of that Sigma capital RK is another
notion of effective rank it's looking at
like the sum of the eigenvalues squared
in that subspace divided by the sum of
the squares ok so just thinking about a
couple of exam and these two are pretty
closely related to each other so
important but thinking about a couple of
examples of these effective ranks you
know if we take an identity matrix of
finite dimension the effective rank is
just the rank of that matrix
alright so it's you can think of it as
counting counting the dimension but of
course it works for infinite infinite
matrices too and one way to think about
it is you know if we think of something
that has rank P but is not necessarily
completely symmetric as the identity
matrix is then you know we get something
that looks like in both cases looks like
the rank times some notion of symmetry
right the the rank times you know some
other notion of symmetry for these two
and the notion of symmetry is you know
looking at kind of how far we are from
that of that identity or constant times
identity situation so these notions of
symmetry lie between you know the
smallest case is where you really only
have a 1 dimensional thing and this
looks like kind of 1 over P in both
cases and the the biggest value of these
these s's is 1 right so it's some it's
some number between kind of 0 & 1
that gives us this effective rank
slightly different this one's bigger
than this one but not too much behind in
some sense ok so so they're telling us
you know how much is is going what's the
effect of rank in this subspace
orthogonal to the K highest energy
directions and the theorem says you know
K star here is when we first get down
below get get to a subspace that has
this
effective ranked big compared to end
right so we have kind of n n equally
important directions right now we don't
want to have that if we have that at the
start where we're in deep trouble right
but once we get on through K K
dimensions we find a subspace that has
kind of n think of it as an equally
important directions that defines our K
star better happen pretty fast and then
you know this is the rank the this other
notion of effective rank of that Cubs
subspace and we better have that big
compared to it so these are the these
are the two notions of the effective
rank of these subspaces that appear in
these upper and lower bounds okay so so
that's the that's the characterization
you know the intuition I guess I'll say
a little bit about the proof in a moment
but you know these eigenvalues of the
covariance matrix we should think of
them as telling us how important
different directions are in parameter
space right so the the eigenvalues
determine in in in this problem two
things one is how that label noise gets
distributed through the feeder hats so
the the big lambda I directions get a
lot of label noise the small lambda
right directions get not very much it's
sort of controlling that and as I say
it's also affecting how errors in our
estimate of theta affect predictive
accuracy and it's the balance of those
two things result about excess error and
and the message of the theorem is if we
want to avoid harming prediction
accuracy we've got to take all that
noise energy that's in the in the labels
and distributed across lots of
unimportant directions right so this
this big effective rank of a subspace is
telling us you know there's a high
energy or a highly important subspace
and we get things right there and then
there's this other sub space where we
can bury all the noise that's that's the
kind of intuition of the
characterization so you know over
parameterization is essential for this
benign overfitting for being able to
interpolate and still have good
predictive accuracy
it's necessary we're over
parameterization is defined in terms of
these effective rates so okay so what is
what are the conditions we need we need
lots of nonzero eigenvalues we certainly
need to have that in overarch a better
have a denominator that's bigger than K
right so lots and lots of directions
where the noise can be can be very the
sum of those of those eigen values
should be small compared to n I I guess
the sum of all of the eigen values
should be small too compared to n this
is just like a scaling scaling thing the
the number of the of these small
eigenvalues once we've neglected this
initial subspace there should be many of
those compared to N and you know if
they're symmetric just needs to be large
compared to n if they're asymmetric
right so we have a tail out there then
you know we need way more than it it's
the ideal case is to have lots of
roughly roughly similar values of small
small eigenvalues out in that tail okay
so let me say fifteen minutes so let me
say a little bit about the about the
proof I also want to get on to a kind of
couple of implications but just just to
say a little bit about the proof the the
the key idea I mean there's a classical
kind of decomposition we can think of
the expected loss as arising from two
components one that comes from the
signal and one that comes from the noise
all right so you know the the signal is
take the least squares parameter vector
the the parameter vector that gives the
smallest predictive accuracy and and
think about what it would predict versus
all the rest and called call the rest
the noise and and those two pieces give
us you know quite a quite a nice view of
what our so our theta hat so they lead
to two components of the excess risk the
first component is is you know we don't
quite get theta star popping up from
from the signal part because
you know we're getting a somewhat
distorted view of the covariance of X in
training data and the second component
that component due to the error is I
think more interesting so first
component is really not a problem even
in high dimensions you can use classical
methods to keep control of that the
second component is is really the
problematic interesting one it's the
impact of the noise on our parameter
vector right so that's the heart of the
problem so okay so we do this this
decomposition into you know define a
noise vector that is whatever else would
be there on top of what the the theta
star would predict and estimator here
you know by writing our Y as this sum
you get two pieces to feed a hat we get
a piece that's due to theta star and a
piece that's due to Epsilon things
become decomposed beautifully in the
linear case and then that gives us two
pieces of the excess risk this quantity
you know how what what our excess
expected squared error is above the
theta star the optimal one the first
piece as I say it's you know we can use
classical methods to keep control of in
the second piece is the one due to the
noise it's much more interesting okay so
what happens with that second piece all
right there are a few steps here you
know we can we can rewrite this pseudo
inverse in terms of something like a
gram matrix
alright so consider inner products
between all pairs of the points in our
sample and then we get something that
you know generically is going to be
invertible certainly in the gaussian
case and we have an alternative
expression and now we can we can scale
things whiten things I guess to get to
get something in terms of standard
normals standard normal vectors so this
is now an N by n matrix right and this
thing is an N by you know something very
large kind of matrix on either side so
we can rescale things to get it in terms
of standard normal these are n n vectors
standard normal vectors and that matrix
in the middle is a is a weighted sum of
standard normal outer products of
dimension n so you know you can believe
you could do something like that
ignoring the detail turns out actually
I'll skip over I'll skip over that we
have some extra there's there's some
nice you can use a shermann morrison
kind of approach to say actually I can
write this thing which involves a
standard normal and a matrix here that
includes in it some some of these
standard normals in particular this one
is also there but we can exclude that
one you know you can write things in
terms of a matrix that doesn't include
this particular vector so you have a
ratio of things that involve just you
know an independent standard normal and
a matrix that has other standard normals
at a high level we're just splitting
things up into keeping keeping control
of those things and and in the
non-gaussian case you know you get a
similar thing with with instead of
standard normals you have independent
isotropic random variables ok and then
there's a concentration piece once we
get down through these K dimensions into
this subspace once we're in this regime
what this is telling us is that in that
subspace the two pieces that determine
concentration of things like the the
let's say behavior of the the matrices
that pop up there some of the
eigenvalues and the largest eigenvalue
they're they're the crucial quantities
well once we're in this regime it's the
sum of the eigenvalues that matters all
right and the largest eigenvalue is its
effect it's dominated and and that means
that the eigenvalues most of the
eigenvalues of these matrices that we're
considering are kind of the same within
constant factors of of something that we
can get our hands on so there's a
crucial concentration part that arises
from that first condition involving the
the first use of this effective rank and
then we can split things up you know
into the heavy directions the ones in
this first k biggest eigenvalues which
which cost us one over N in terms of
excess prediction accuracy and then
those other directions which cost us
something like n over this other notion
of range
so you know skating over a lot of detail
and the lower bound is really you know
the same kind of decomposition so it's
that second term that's really the
interesting one and two cases when
things are concentrated so when that
when that rank condition is satisfied we
get a lower bound that's within a
constant factor of the upper bound when
things are not concentrated we get a
lower bound that's at least a constant
anyway so you know that's where the
matching up and okay so that's a
whirlwind view of the at a high level of
the arguments that go into you know why
why we get this characterization okay so
let's think about some consequences
first one is you know we we've got a
condition that really is just saying
what is the mean assuming that okay
let's give it assuming that this thing
is just a constant right then then and
and you know actually ignoring ignoring
essentially this term and just focusing
on this term you know all we're worrying
about here are properties of the eigen
values of c1 you know properties of this
kind of mix of importance of different
directions in parameter space okay so
what one of those properties look like
let's think about the case of having a
our sample size getting large and asking
well when can we make this kind of
quantity that arises in theorem go to
zero right so as n gets large you know
what does this K star look like of
course it's a function of N and what
does what does this this term look like
and in what circumstances can we make
these things go to zero so you can you
know it turns out you can characterize
them in many different examples here's
one example if you want to get
polynomial decay of the lambda rise all
right so I to the minus alpha and I'll
put a log factor in there because turns
out we need it then we have this
asymptotically benign property precisely
when that exponent alpha is 1 and and
beta is bigger than 1 all right so
you've got to have things decaying
just at the very edge of some ability so
you know this is sort of the slowest
decay that lets you this form that lets
you sum up those those eigenvalues it is
it is but you know I mean it's sort of
the first thing that you would that you
would check here right so so yes we get
we get a result that's entirely finite
sample but then saying well what a what
is this it's it's all about the sequence
if I can I can value so what is what are
sequences that make things work
just just asymptotically first okay so
you know this looks bad right this looks
like the only asymptotics that make it
work or lambdas that are right at the
edge of not being summable which is kind
of striking so you know this this is a
little a little surprising to see this
characterization of that sort of
asymptotic result but it turns out you
know you can if you chop off the
dimension at some point and include some
okay so so let's let's think about this
this example a little carefully so so if
we're in a finite dimension let's call
that dimension P sub n right the that as
n increases we want this dimension to
increase obviously but let's make it P
sub in and our eigen values are
something that decays fast I've written
it as e to the minus K that part's not
really important right so fast decay of
the eigen values plus some isotropic
right so there's this spherically
symmetric component I'll call epsilon in
in every direction and and presumably
it's small right so there's a fast
decaying part as we move as we move down
through the eigenvalues and there's a
constant part and and Beyond piece are
there nothing nothing's going on okay
then we get things behave nicely right
we get this nice performance in the
sense that the the prediction the excess
risk goes to zero as a function of n as
long as we have lots of directions big
it it's being compared to N and the
total energy in all those directions is
small compared to end
okay so the total energy I mean of this
constant piece is small compared in okay
so you know this is enough together with
some other little condition that
actually you can't have these epsilon0
raid you can't just have a fast decay
and precise as euros everywhere precise
zero is added in so as long as it's
small not too small but not too small
it's like exponentially yeah so that's a
really mild condition and you know you
can make it quantitative with with
constants I've written Big O but you
know you make a quantitative for this
sort of example you get you know the
total energy in this isotropic piece
divided by n plus something like 1 over
N as long as your P P sub n is big
enough okay so so you know very nice
control the excess rusi in this case as
long as this total energy is not
ridiculously small and really is
ridiculously small if you think about
you know what this kind of quantity
looks like it's down at below the level
of machine precision you know once once
n is bigger than a few dozen all right
so so you know this this feels much more
like a universal phenomenon that you
you're cutting off it at P sub n as long
as it's much bigger than n and you've
got some level of isotropic kind of
noise in the X's in all directions then
everything behaves nicely ok so that's
the second example ok I want to talk
about two kinds of implications the
first one is thinking going back to this
deep learning phenomenon what what does
this tell us about deep learning so
there's a whole bunch of work and you
know and I apologize I'm I'm sure this
slide is already way out of date there's
a whole bunch of work that looks at at
these kinds of linear approximations of
the functions that get computed by a
neural networks trained with with a
gradient descent with a small step size
the random initialization you can think
of that as you know in in some
appropriate condition with very large
width of the network you can think of it
as the the network can be accurately
approximated by
the first order Taylor series
approximation to the function that you
get at the initialization at the random
initialization of the parameters so
that's linear right and so you know you
might think of applying these results in
that sort of setting I mean their
specific conditions that we give for
that we need on the components of our
other X's are not going to be satisfied
in that in that setting but I actually
think you know that's not a an
especially productive direction you know
I don't think that sort of architecture
is is very realistic and does seem like
it's unlikely they're considering just
random features is going to give us much
of the story of generalization in these
networks so I think there's a lot more
to to do in the direction of deep
networks okay and the second thing I
wanted to briefly mention is you know
what does this say about adversarial
examples if you're doing an
interpolating linear prediction rule
you're putting all the label noise in
the theta hat I mean it's it's trivial
to see that you're going to have some
very very sensitive direction right so
you know if you so you can always find a
direction a unit norm vector it's
proportional to you know where the noise
pushed your parameter vector that unit
norm vector that direction is a
direction where you're hugely sensitive
if you perturb an input in that
direction then the output changes hugely
so even if that direction has is
orthogonal to the to the least squares
thing so you would start off with no
sensitivity in that direction making
making optimal predictions you have no
sensitivity in that direction you still
have you know the the sensitivity to
perturbations of the inputs in that
direction is huge it scales like at
least like Sigma over the square root of
this lambda K star plus 1 the biggest
Tigan value in this direction and this
needs to be small you know a very loose
lower bound here is saying you know
you've got something here that's like 1
over ignoring the scaling of the noise
it's like 1 over the quantity that
appears in the excess risk
but so that's ridiculously sensitive if
you want your excess risk to get small
this quantity is going to get is like
one over the accessories will be smaller
because it's one term in the accessories
so so you know having good performance
in this setting good predictive accuracy
in this setting means that you have huge
sensitivity to the pet direction how
could we distinguish operationally mean
yeah that's a very good question
I it's unclear right I mean I think we
in a regime where we get good predictive
accuracy out of this interpolating
prediction rule you know we're in this
very high dimensional setting where some
directions inevitably have a very big
sensitivity you know if we're choosing
random perturbations if we choose X
according the original distribution
we're not going to see those directions
right because they're low weight
direction but but if we adversary choose
them then then you know you can find a
direction that's hugely sensitive how
could we detect you know the difference
between a sensitivity to a something
that came from epsilon versus versus a
sensitivity that something that came
from you know theater-style good
predictions yeah that's a good question
it's not clear
okay so you know I think I think this
sort of won over the excess risk makes
it clear that you get huge sensitivity
okay so let me conclude so the the you
know big interesting direction I think
is is extending these sorts of these
sorts of results to nonlinear cases to
things like deep networks understanding
what happens in the interpolating regime
or close to the interpolating regime
which i think is is seems to be where
where the action is in so moving beyond
thinking of approximating a deep net by
its first order Taylor series
approximation and directions I think are
really interesting what's the analog of
the minimum norm linear prediction rule
in the in the deep network setting you
know what is it that these sort of
optimization methods that are widely use
provide for us in analogous sense what
the implications for regularization to
okay so just to sum up so you know this
is this is a regime that's really far
from from classical statistical sort of
approaches right I think it's really
fascinating that we can that we can get
in this regime where there is apparently
no trade-off between the fit to the data
and laxity of the prediction rule
because you have a perfect fit to the
data
you know that's it's amazing that we can
we can still get good predictive
accuracy the characterization here for
linear regression is you know we want to
have this this ability to hide the noise
in lots of unimportant directions that's
really what's what's going on and it's a
characterization it's necessary and
sufficient and that sort of long flat
tail of the covariance eigenvalues
so it relies on the over
parameterization but it's not just many
parameters but many very unimportant
parameters and in some sense equally
unimportant they equally unimportant
forever but you know one of the bad
consequences is this huge sensitivity to
all right one or two questions to be
here and I hope the thing be somewhere
here Oh giant has a paper bounds on
[Applause]
i what i described up here was X Waze is
Gaussian jointly Gaussian so so it
suffice us to have X in this sort of
form that the random matrix people
assume so X has lots of independence
driving it if you want to if you want to
make a second order if you want to
whiten the X then you can write it as
Sigma to the half times a big matrix
with lots of independent components all
right so you need lots of independence
driving the X in some sense and then you
just need sub girl sir everything
somebody else on to get all the
concentration results we need I think
the second Direction is much more
interesting you know I think
approximating things by linear classes I
I wouldn't put my money on that I guess
let's put it that way
maybe one last question have you look at
analogy to the winner filter where are
you doing spectral density of signal or
relative of the noise and cz2 right down
to error in terms of respect respect
fence is very much yeah I mean it's
essentially this is this is a
nonparametric linear linear approach so
in that sense they're really very very
much the same in that case you're tied
to P equals and thank you speaking in
joy and you're working in in this
specific linear transformation of the
input that's that's very much a similar
things but here you know thinking about
p equals n that won't work right in some
sense so when you're when you're keeping
the dimension that you work in right at
or near the sample size you're in
trouble you know the lower bound shows
you you're in trouble there do you
actually need to work in some some
higher dimensional space which is what
rises in this spectral
[Applause]